bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions qu'attendre de ce sommet de la
cedeao quelle marge de manoeuvre
réellement pour l'instance ouest
africaine
bonjour alors je précise que je ne suis
pas abidjan je suis à conakry en ce
moment 1 voit la pause pour préciser
alors la cedeao
le bonheur je pense surtout que l'acid
house va se contenter de sanction
relativement basique un peu comme le
mali il ya un an à savoir peut-être des
sanctions économiques des suspensions
des instances régionales des exigences
évidemment certainement la libération du
président alpha condé l'instauration
être d'une structure étatique relative
même si mitterrand font partie et puis
bien sûr et respect démocratique de base
mais je ne pense pas que la cedeao la
soie pour l'instant en mesure de faire
de sanctions véritablement autre que
symbolique
donc ce sommet véritablement à quoi il
faire alors si c'est simplement
symbolique
en même temps est-ce qu'ils ont le choix
il ya quand même à présent qui a été
renversé dans le constructeur qui a été
bousculé les chefs d'état et les
instances régionales d'autre choix que
de s'y réunir parce qu'il s'agit tout de
même d'une véritable crise politique il
faudrait pas que cela se transforme
comme à l'époque du cd de moussa dadis
camara entre 2008 et 2009 donc la cedeao
je pense se réunir pour voir voir de
quelle manière on peut commencer à
discuter avec le comité national du
rassemblement et de la ddt et du
développement pardon tu donc la nouvelle
junte militaire aujourd'hui aux affaires
en guinée pour déjà faire des sanctions
a minima au moins commencer à dire d'un
condamné de moscou d'état et puis
commencer peut-être à discuter mettre
des exigences des options voir comment
ça a été comme un peuple comme pour
considérer le cnrd comme un partenaire
avec lequel on peut causer
coup d'état militaire au nom de la lutte
contre la corruption mais quelles sont
les réelles intentions sur l'embout des
putschistes vous qui êtes donc à conakry
véritable combat anti corruption ou
simple désir de de pouvoir
et si tu la question pour l'instant on
ne connaît pas la guinée même habitué
aux coups d'état militaires la seule
nouveauté c'est que c'est la première
fois que un président en exercice et
démis par l'armée généralement l'armée
attend que le président meurt après elle
prend le pouvoir bousculer l'ordre
constitutionnel et l'a ensuite ça
arrange pousse à prendre des postes
s'arranger des postes et puis faire une
transition mais l'a écouté pour
l'instant on est avant tout à des actes
d'intention qui sont pour l'instant en
tout cas permettre tout cas d'avoir
l'adhésion de la population la
population paraît en tout cas en très
grande majorité adhérer à ce cnrd donc
pour l'instant on ne peut pas vraiment
s'avancer sur les intentions réelles des
nouveaux hommes forts du pays
et quid de la transition politique on a
vu ainsi hier les putschistes relâcher
certains
certains moments ex membres ou des
personnalités proches du président déchu
alpha condé coût de cette transition
politique parce qu'on a vu hier la
cedeao se montrer sceptique sur la
transition au mali par exemple pour
respecter les délais impartis
ou alors moi je le garderai de le
comparer au mali elle a une dîner 602
bidamant différence ce sont deux
histoires de situation totalement
différente
donc je me garderai de faire des
comparaisons on peut il faudrait
peut-être évité de mettre l'afrique dans
un même panier le prix alpha condé était
quand même dans une obstination et qui
essaime isolé au niveau régional donc la
guinée est un cas très particulier dans
ce cas précis ensuite il ya eu hier des
libérations de prisonniers politiques un
cas définis dans le comme tels parce que
considérés comme étant en fait des deux
otages en quelque sorte du régime alpha
condé s'est prise et anthony dod et
libéré des prisonniers politiques
l'opposition et aussi des militants les
civils qui a appelé à lutter conte de
trois moines d'alpha condé ce sont des
mesures qui dans tous les cas sont de
nature à adhérer encore plus
macaq acquérir par l'adhésion de la
population de manière encore plus forte
pour démontrer que 20 nouveaux pouvoirs
et là on va encore une fois il faut que
je pense qu'il faut encore faire preuve
de patience le il faut se rappeler quand
même qu'il ya douze ans les plus de 10
ans il ya deux entre
camara avait également cité énormément
d'espoir de la population guinéenne
avant très rapidement de de provoquer
des inquiétudes et ses inquiétudes ont
ensuite mené massacre du 28 septembre
combien de temps va durer cette période
d'instabilité
selon vous parce que vous venez de dire
que globalement la population guinéenne
soutient ce coup d'état
mais si cette période d'instabilité
venait à durer trop longtemps est ce que
la population pourrait changer son fusil
d'épaulé
l'autre longtemps sa dépense considère
comme étant trop longtemps dans lequel
la guinée je pense que la transition bon
je ne peux pas vraiment dire venez de
m'estime estime yves durée pour
l'instant il n'y a absolument aucun
calendrier ça c'est sûr ils sont
exigeants de la part des politiques
suspect civile également les instances
régionales des chefs d'état de la
sous-région qui demande d'avoir un
calendrier de transition extrêmement
clair il y aura au moins une année je
suppose il faut au moins un an à voir
maintenant ça ne durera plus longtemps
mais pour l'instant on est vraiment dans
le flou on est vraiment pour l'instant
je pense la construction de d'une forme
d'état militaire voir ensuite définir
clairement les conditions à venir pour
la formation d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale ce qui a été promis par l'ue
tant colonel mamadou niang merci s'il y
en a ce n'est d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous étiez donc
on directeur de conakry la capitale de
la guinée vous êtes donc journaliste
spécialiste de la guinée